it's not about this.first the bronze
your money you promoted it and that's
now on DVD and I remember when this
movie came out and watching it really
funny idea for a movie and you do such a
good job in it then we'll be begins with
a very racy scene am I correct
it does it begins with me pleasuring
myself to a VHS of a bronze
medal-winning gymnastics performance yes
and so and trust me who among us has not
done that but what's interesting is it
okay now it's been a while since the
movie came out now the DVD comes out and
I'm thinking you're probably starting to
hear from people that didn't watch it in
the theater but they're seeing that
scene now is that happening yeah so yeah
there's that scene and then there's this
big gymnastics X scene and so what's
happening is these people really want to
see the movie there is a gymnastic sex
scene yesterday Jim nasty he's making
less sense is that what's happening is
that people in my life these seemingly
wholesome acquaintances are now
revealing themselves to me as like
full-on perverts that's what the
discovery for me is bit like the dry
cleaner that I go to has been saying
things like so I I saw the movie finally
and I I watching you slow it down I can
start to see where you end and your body
double begins and what you're just
trying to get you directly yeah and I
played ball I mean I needed my shirt
back so and so do you get rid of this
guy because I think that would just be
weird you can't keep using that dry
cleaner I mean now I feel like I have an
in though to get my clothes back a
little sooner write him out of the loop
completely yeah cut him out of the loop
now on Big Bang Theory your character
Bernadette is pregnant and I want to ask
you about this you get to experience a
fake pregnancy but you wear the
pregnancy outfit those things are pretty
realistic is it how is that I do it's
nice to have like it's like a built-in
shelf so I'm like just using like my
laptop on there and like balancing a
drink on there it's been interesting
though my parents I had to call them the
night before the episode aired when they
were just announcing the Burnet
pregnancy and I was like just to warn
you they're not writing and
in for me it's it's just tea because
like my parents and like all their
friends they sort of treat BIGBANG like
a reality show so they think anytime I'm
doing anything on the show that it's
happening in real life so you had
probably people back home where is back
home Jersey Jersey yeah and what are
they thinking they're thinking okay
Melissa is now pregnant rather than your
characters preg totally they're
congratulating my parents my parents
wins like the bagel store my dad got
free bagels which in New Jersey like
that's the greatest sign of respect to
get a free bagel
that's like a Congressional Medal of
Honor I'd rather have a bagel than the
medal now you told me you talked about
your folks before their characters you
obviously you love them but they're
there seems like they're funny without
even trying to be funny like when
they're being sincere funny things
happen exactly yeah my mom is the queen
of those moments like so years we had
this childhood dog who lived well into
my adult you who lived til like 21 years
old okay and he had enlarged testicles
towards the end of his life so we all
got to a point where we decided we had
to put this dog down it was so sad and
we're all in the room together my
parents my brother my husband and we're
all saying our goodbyes to our beloved
dog lucky and like we love you like you
so much goodbye goodbye and the last
words this dog heard was my mom saying
it's okay lucky no more big balls thing
the pain is over go ahead
go to a better place with no more
and I love that she's great
the back just kind of looked over yours
like oh I'll leave you yeah yeah I think
I shouldn't give you some time now I
want those to be the last words I hear I
don't even know what its gonna mean I
know what it means
you